[Music]
all right
muhammad al balushi from
ireland okay
we play e4 as you guys know
e45 and we continue playing the four
night scotch which is our opening in the
speed run knight f3 i assume knight c6
happens by the way another good thing
about the four night scotch is that you
don't have to learn a separate line
against the petrov you can just play
knight c3
so it saves you some work not that the
petrov is popular holmes thank you for
the five okay d6
well that's sort of one could say
a souped-up philidor
it doesn't particularly change our
reaction i mean d4 is still a perfectly
good move here
uh in fact d6 is actually quite passive
so why not you know why not
he takes d4 knight takes d4
and we have an advan i mean this this is
a very common way of playing at this
level right black just trades everything
on d4 but our queen is very well placed
here and that's what's important to
understand is that
c5 is not a is it's not a threat if
black plays c5 he only weakens uh his
position even further like the d6 pawn
becomes a huge weakness and then the d5
square becomes a potential outpost for
for one of our pieces
probably the knight
so don't be afraid as i always as i like
to say of your queen being attacked
your queen being attacked is not
inherently dangerous it can be in
certain situations but it isn't always
how should we continue developing where
should we position our bishops
yeah so bishop g5 i think is natural and
strong
and since we've already gotten our queen
out of d1 it makes sense to castle
queenside here in the principled the
principled path here is the castle queen
side and then to steamroll black on the
king side and in the center thank you
champ for the five subs my goodness
it's not ending and there's c5
there's c5 it's a very very common move
at this level
um
sort of falling in love with the idea of
attacking the queen
now here it's important not to rush into
a particular move it's quite an
important decision
uh the question of where to put the
queen
and
that question already contains the seeds
of a mistake because the best move is
believe it or not not with a queen
the best move is not with a queen of
might suggesting we sacrifice the queen
no i am not what am i what am i
suggesting
yeah i'm suggesting that we deliver a
bishop check on b5
now what is that likely to lead to and
why are we doing that well after bishop
b5 check black is likely to cover it
with his bishop right bishop d7
then we trade bishops on d7 and who can
tell me why the trait of light squared
bishops is good for white from a
positional standpoint
i'm talking positionally i'm not talking
about tactics right now
from the standpoint of what i just
explained our main advantages are
yes so d5 becomes even weaker imagine
black's bishop sits on e6 and it somehow
controls d5 somewhat controls d5 if the
light squared bishops are gone
then really there's nothing that can
control d5 and we can always capture
this knight when we want to and slam
that knight into d5 so we
we have to be a little bit careful here
actually
the funny thing is
if we take on d7 immediately there's
believe it or not the move knight takes
d7
this reminds me of a famous trap
and that leads us to an end game that we
have to properly evaluate so bishop
takes d7 knight takes d7
now in that position if we take the pawn
on g7 that would be a terrible blunder
because bishop takes g5 is check
so after bishop takes d7 knight takes c7
we have to play bishop takes c7
black takes our queen
we take black's queen
black's pawn takes our knight
then our bishop on d8 is hanging it has
to drop back to h4
and in that resulting end game white is
much better
and i don't know if you guys are are
visualizing that position or not but
essentially the pawn on d6 and that
resulting end game
is going to be lost it's it's toast
but that's an important line to
calculate
i don't know if that made sense
it was a mood point queen takes d7
happened as i thought it would
now we have to figure out a good square
for the queen so we need a square
where the queen is simultaneously active
but it's not in the way of other pieces
so for example on e3 i think it would be
in the way of other pieces it would walk
into knight g4
on d3 it would be in the way of the i
want the rook on d1
to exert an x-ray against the queen
so i want to get the queen off of the
d-file
but not on e3 well that only leaves us
with one square i really like the c4
square
it's it's putting pressure on black's
position b5 is not dangerous because
we're
defending that square twice
and
you might contemplate the question of
why i why i was so keen
on establishing the x-ray well what move
does this does that allow us to play now
that allows us to play a very very
powerful move yeah the movie five is
kind of a no-brainer here just forces
the knight back and black's position
starts to doesn't start to collapse
black's position simply is on the verge
of collapsing here
and it all happened because he's played
the move c5 which greatly weakened
black's center it weakened the d6 spawn
it weakened the square and and
positionally speaking that's almost a
decisive mistake black has to be very
very careful here not to lose
i'm sort of expecting to move knight g4
and that does lose the game
it loses a piece to bishop take c7 but
you know
players often struggle to
to figure out the right approach in a
position like this
uh this is a philidor by transposition
yeah 98 is correct but 98 will end up
losing a pawn and not only will that end
up losing a pawn but
black's position will also suck in that
resulting position
so h6 here doesn't work if if black
plays h6 then we can still take the
knight with our pawn and we are
simultaneously attacking the bishop that
doesn't work
uh d5 also doesn't work because we can
ignore everything and take the knight
with our pawn that is why we established
the x-ray against the d-pawn precisely
for that reason so d5e takes f6
and if black takes our queen
then we take black screen and we're up
we're up a piece because we took a
knight and black didn't take any of our
miners 98 good stuff by our opponent
now there's a couple of approaches in
this position
we're going to take the very simple
approach of releasing the tension and
winning upon
how do we do that what am i talking
about
i'll show you after the game another
interesting way to play this position
but we're not going to over overthink it
or overdo it here we're going to take
the bishop we're going to take the pawn
and then the c5 pawn and that's pretty
symbolic that the c5 pawn that was
weakened
uh ultimately falls and it falls with a
pin so black not only loses a pawn but
look at how flimsy black's position is
as a result
our rook is coming into e1 our knight is
coming into d5
so we have tremendous potential energy
among our pieces so black is down upon
and his position is terrible
it's not just the material loss
black must be extremely cautious not to
lose more material
rook
fda good move
now roxy8 doesn't help could be the rook
c8 we we can take the knight with our
queen because the rook is also guarding
that spot
okay so what should we do
well
um
we can try to win the game we can try to
win the game immediately with the move
knight b5 going after the knight
um but as it turns out knight b5 is not
successful
it might work in this game but who sees
the current yeah we're going to play
rook h1 we're going to play the natural
move
but before we do that who can tell me
why knight b5 is unsuccessful
it's not an easy move by the way yeah
knight b5 rook a to c8
and if the queen drops back along the
diagonal the black has the sudden queen
g5 check
forking the knight end
uh and the king and that's why king b1
in such situations is a very good move
to throw in but in this case we're just
going to go over kg1 bring the rook into
the game
and if the queen drops back to f8 i'm
thinking
it's not a bad idea to just go king b1
just so we don't have to ever worry
about
tactics related to the king sticking out
on c1 ever again
the alternative is to go knight d5 and
continue improving our pieces in fact
i like knight d5 a little bit more let's
just let's just go knight t5 let's not
worry about king b1 yet
because now that the queen has dropped
back to f8 we don't truly have to worry
about our king being on c1 right
i'm hoping for rook aca because we have
a very very nice idea
if rook ac8 happens but i think it will
happen it's a very natural move now what
is white threatening here well
of course we are building our play based
on peace activity we're also playing
against the knight on d6 which is
a tremendously flimsy piece
we're threatening the move 97 check
which slices off the queen's connection
to the night and then we will be able to
take the night with our with our rook
that's partially we didn't play rookie
one only for that reason it just gets
the rook to an open file those are the
best moves if you can make a move that
simultaneously creates a threat but it
also
but it also
improves let's say the position of a
piece that's the ideal world b6 is a
great move our opponent is playing well
where should we move our queen
so we cannot play knight e7 check that
would be a blunder
that would be a blunder due to queen
takes e7
and remember that in that resulting
position our queen is also hanging it
would blunder a piece we have to speed
up just a little bit
the best approach in such positions as
yasser would say
is to keep the queen as a supporting
actress to not over involve the queen
and to keep it on a
square where it operates from a distance
but it doesn't compromise its
effectiveness and that's ultimately why
queens and bishops are so good right the
queen on a3 is doing exactly the same
work that it was doing from c5 but now
it's no longer vulnerable to moves like
b6 and rook c8 does that make sense
so now we don't have to worry about the
queen getting caught up rook d7 a great
move
now i think we should continue building
our play against the knight on d6 and we
should do that by doubling rooks on the
d file let's let's play the move rook d3
and this move carries a couple of
purposes
we could lift the rook to g3 and create
threats like knight f6
but we're also preparing to double rooks
on d1 and ultimately we're trying to get
the knight to move so that we can trade
queens and get into a pawn up end game
this
i probably is our first game that's
really not you know not straightforward
on a straightforward win our opponent is
defending very very well
why not queen before that was an
alternative the only reason i put my
queen on a3 rather than before is
because on a3 it's and just as i say
that of course a huge blunder as always
uh the queen here is protected by a pawn
that is literally the only reason i put
it on a3 and not on b4
yeah i mean
g6 inexplicable move knight f6 check and
i guess it is explicable just the fact
that black is under so much pressure for
so long it it causes irrational moves
like that one and that blunders the rook
and also black loses okay i guess he
doesn't lose the knight but he does lose
the rook and guess what it would have
been nice if we had played king b1 queen
h6 wouldn't have been possible
okay and now where should the queen go
well our queen is attacked
as soon as g6 is played you should be
paying the most attention to the long
diagonal
obviously the queen goes to c3 and picks
off the knight
easy easy as cake
okay knight e5 i mean this is just
desperation
if you want to play
[Music]
if you want to play in a classy fashion
probably taking with a knight is the
best to set up a discover check
uh but we can take with anything we want
it it really doesn't matter let's just
take the queen let's just stick with a
queen with check
it it doesn't matter and our opponent is
disconnected
and resigned
good good stuff
okay well uh
e45 yeah so so d6 is a strange move that
is unnecessary knight f6 of course is is
the main move
uh we we decided on d4 and i i guess it
would make sense for black here to play
the move bishop g4 that would seem to be
the consecutive approach
e takes d4 and knight takes d4 is just
incredibly passive this bishop is bad
our pieces are
nicely placed in the center and so
you know black's position is already
very iffy
and the move c5 i would go so far as to
say that it's almost a decisive mistake
and i hope that i was able to explain
fully why this move is so bad
it creates all of these long-term
weaknesses and it doesn't have anything
going for it literally the only virtue
of this move is that it attacks the
queen and that's not inherently a good
thing
and this is something i'm really trying
to hammer into into your head
you should never make a move just
because it threatens a piece unless
you're losing and you're trying to set a
trap and you're hoping for a blunder
first of all you shouldn't play in a way
where you hope for blunders
threats can be good but they can't be
good just because they're threats
they have to do something else like the
threat has to be unstoppable or it has
to be part of a larger plan
and this should be five check is just a
good example of not
reacting automatically but really
searching for the maximum
and of course as long as your your
opponent's king is uncastled you should
always be aware of checks along this
diagonal you should just keep an eye out
for for moves like bishop b5 and queen
a4 and stuff like that
yeah black sh black should castle here
black should castle in black's position
is okay i mean we probably would have
put this bishop on d3 where it
potentially aims at the king after e5
and black is worse i mean no question
about it we can bring the pawn up to f4
black's position is very cramped here
but it's not structurally unsound
black's position is still structurally
sound
um
so hopefully this move makes sense now
here's the hilarious thing
this idea of going knight takes d7 and
exposing an attack against the bishop is
a very well-known trap
in another line
there's a very well-known trap
uh and even strong grandmasters have
fallen into this trap throughout history
and it has very similar contours and
i'll show you guys the most famous
example
where tigran petrossian
defeated a dutch grandmaster named hans
ree
in eight moves in a very important game
in the olymp in the wake ons a actually
in what was then known as joha veins but
now is tata steel
1971.
okay so english c4 e5
knight c3 knight f6 knight f3 knight c6
g3 it's a symmetrical english right i
mean how is it possible that this game
lasts only four more moves well bishop
b4 and knight d5 this is uh
a viable oh no no this is the wrong game
sorry this is also a very cool game i
confused this is a different game
but i'll show you guys this one as well
this is a really cool trap too
but i i confused this with with
something else um
so c takes d5
and here thank you shy king hans ri i'll
i'll find the other game as well don't
worry
hans ray goes e4
counter-attacking white's knight
the funny thing is after dcef and this
is a good illustration of
you know the importance of undefended
pieces and and how damaging it can be to
have a single undefended piece on the
board after white's next move black
resigned
and then i'll find the other game
after blacksmith after white's next move
black resigned
yeah the move is queen b3
well what's so great about this move
well the bishop has to move
if black defends it white can simply
attack it one way or another the bishop
is going to have to move but it can't
move because if it moves
then you give up b7 with the fork
it's just nothing the plaque can do i
mean black and play f takes c2 but
white's just gonna recapture that
doesn't change anything
yeah wayne b3 wins the game that's a
cool one
right so this is a pretty strong game
why was a guy named doris gavitch
doris kevich was
an international master very competent
russian player
black was tuk makov who
is still alive and he's a very strong gm
so watch what happens this is also in
english that's why i confused it
um
this time black goes f5 d4 e4 and do you
guys see why i mean it's a similar kind
of
position because after bishop g5 knight
f6
again white goes with this d5 move
e takes f3
d takes c6
f takes g2 already white is in trouble
white has to play bishop takes g2 and
give up the pawn but as you can
understand white plays c takes d7 check
and thought okay bishop takes d7 bishop
takes g2
and uh
you know and and and white is fine but
what did black do in this position
and hopefully you can see how this
dovetails in with
uh the move my opponent had
so what should black do here
oh my takes d7 yeah knight takes d7 and
white resigned
because the bishop is hanging
so if you take on g2 you use the bishop
if you take the queen or if you do
anything else white takes the rook and
promotes to a queen why does it like
black is a rook up
so just remember this concept you know
this is how you learn about these types
of patterns right you just keep adding
to your
your arsenal of ideas
and eventually you just start seeing the
stuff at the board so this is how i was
able to find this move this is how i saw
it i just know this trick
um
so here it's not the same but because
after bishop takes c7
c takes d4 we've already taken one of
black's pieces so material is going to
be equal now if he takes on d8 then we
take on d4 we're up a pawn what i was
calculating is d takes e3 how do you
evaluate this position well it's not
that hard to evaluate after the bishop
drops back
okay you could trade b2 why does a
slightly damaged pawn structure on the
queen side but look at the d6 pawn it
can't be defended we're going to take it
on the next move and we're going to be
dominating in the end game thank you shy
cry
does that make sense
uh one more thing if black goes knight
c5 trying to counter attack e4
who can tell me should white take on d6
here yes or no
or should white play a move like f3 and
reinforce the pawn first
yes very good you should take on d60
because here you have the move rookie
one
and then you follow up with f3 and the
knight is toast
very good
okay
so
hopefully that makes sense our opponent
probably didn't see that he plays queen
takes d7 queen c4 and already after e5
things are terrible i just wanted to
make one comment after 98
which is that um
well in such positions it can be a good
idea to keep the tension
what does it mean to keep the tension it
means to create a situation where
we are essentially trying to get our
opponents to be the one to trade bishops
so we want to do something such that if
black takes our bishop
uh
it would result in a major concession
what move am i implying here what move
would be possible
this is a classic sort of gm move h4
yeah h4 was a very interesting move and
it is true that black can play h6 and
essentially forces to take but then one
could argue that we've made the move h4
which is beneficial to us and h6 is a
hook
but the point is that if bishop takes g5
h takes g5 happens well this is really
unthinkable for black because now the h
file opens
and black can't tolerate something like
that together with the weakness of his
center
so
you know just a possibility but we
decided to play it simple
now rook he won getting our
getting all the all the toys to the
nursery party knight d5
and just an important note 97 check as i
explained during the game queen takes c7
don't miss these kinds of moves remember
that when your queen is hanging the
rules of engagement are different
and and your opponent can give
his or her queen
at any moment if your queen is hanging
so be very careful about that and so
that's why you should treat these
situations with a lot of caution queen
a3
and i wanted to make one more detour
in order to explain you know this notion
of using the queen as a supporting
actress as as a kind of war general
another way to think about it is using
the queen as a kind of war general
directing things from behind rather than
sort of
uh rather than being in the middle of
everything
sometimes the queen is too valuable to
be in the middle of everything and
sometimes
the queen is just not as effective as
other pieces at
uh at close quarter combat which should
make sense to you because the queen is a
long range piece just like the bishop
and i have a very good example of this
from one of my games i was very proud of
finding this
this idea in one of my games is one of
my first wins against the 2600 plus
rated gm
so this is from a tournament in 2012 i
was in i am at the time
i narrowly missed the norm in this
tournament
my opponent is a 2600 gm
so this is not the like main position
yet it's just that in this position i
made a really nutty move that i want to
share with you
i this is like a classic narrative ski
move so clearly white has this big
attack going right i mean white has this
pawn on f6
and i was thinking about how to attack
g7
so i decided to play
i play the move rook d7 here
um which is not the best move
objectively but practically it's it's
really cute
uh and as you can see the idea is rook
takes d7 queen g4
and i pick up the rook
because of the mate threat against g7
and not only do i pick up the rook but i
do so with interest
because the queen on d7 is is really
really strong
and my opponent drops the screen back to
b6 i go bishop d5
and now queen c7 very strong move
and now the first
nice queen maneuver the first example of
using the queen
and not being afraid to make retreating
moves
what did i do in this position because
clearly a queen trade is out of the
question then the attack evaporates yeah
queen h3 very good queen h3
knight d8 and queen h6
by the way not being afraid of queen
takes c2 check that doesn't do anything
after king a1 white is winning
knight e6 is the only move and now
bishop takes c6
so
my opponent goes with the immediate 96
bishop takes c6 f takes e6 and the point
is that he keeps the queen on c7 where
it guards g7 so there's no checkmate
okay go rook f1
this threatens the move f7
and the critical position occurs after
queen f7 this is
the most important position in the whole
game because this is where i found the
game-winning move
now it may seem logically speaking that
the queen on h6 is white's strongest
piece that may seem
like the case
visually because it looks like okay well
it ties down black's queen it creates
this idea of queen g7 but but that's an
illusion
that's an illusion what's actually tying
down black's queen is not white's queen
it's the combination of white's rook and
white's pawn
if that makes sense because at the
moment the black screen moves away
there's going to be f7 check with
decisive effect right
so you might think about it in a
different way and say okay white's queen
is actually not needed on h6 at the
moment it has to go elsewhere well where
can it go
well another thing that you might notice
here is that the knight on b3 is not
participating in the attack and that
cannot stand because white just doesn't
have enough pieces
to afford one of the pieces being
unemployed
how do you activate the knight well
wouldn't it be great if you could go
knight c5 and the knight d3 and knight
takes e5 well you can't because of the
rook and so i played the move queen e3
when e3 is just very very strong
h6
h6 is a tricky move he wants my queen to
go back i'm like no no no i'm not biting
knight c5
knight d3
95 chasing the queen away and now knight
g4 crushing
he takes c2 that's a meaningless check
after g5
queen h3 black resigned
because he cannot stop this time the
queen infiltrates to h6 but now it's
gonna be checkmate
so i think this is a good example of of
what i'm talking about
and the knight ends up winning the game
um yeah it was a nice finale
and that's uh
that's all she wrote
now transitioning back to the game
yeah i mean g6 and
g6 obviously finishes everything early
but
um
rook 88 rookie d1 black's position is
terrible down upon and under tremendous
pressure there was one more thing i
wanted to show
which is uh what would happen after rook
a to c8
so here
things are a little bit more complicated
you can go knight 97 check but after
queen takes e7 who can crack
my idea what should white do here
and this is a very tricky question
because
i can totally see a move here that might
be tempting to some people but it
doesn't work actually for multiple
reasons yes you guys are all falling for
it i feel empowered queen takes it is
wrong for two reasons the first
you forgot to check well no pun intended
you forgot to check whether black's
queen can move away with check that's
what you have to do
and it can it can go queen g5 check in
your toast because now white's queen is
lost
the second thing black can do is
actually just play knight back take c8
rook takes c7
nope not that rook takes d1 and the
knight takes c7 and black is up a piece
so in reality i faked you out the
solution is a lot simpler you just play
rook takes c7
rook takes c5 and now very importantly
rook takes d6
black is unable to take and since black
is unable to take white is winning in
the end game you've just got
hugely active rooks and you're just
gonna start vacuuming up all of black
spawns you might even double on the
seventh rank
so
that was the idea that i had
just uh slightly complex tactics but
nothing crazy
um and that's that's about it
yeah g6 knight f6 ends the game
and we're over 1500 making progress
but you can see that these games are
starting to become a little bit more
two-sided
and hopefully
you know we can do sort of
more interesting middle game work since
we're not always going to be getting out
of the opening in a winning position
thanks for hanging out guys
lovely stream today and i'll see you
guys later
bye
[Music]